an emergency appeal by the united
nations has brought in pledges of more
than a billion dollars in aid for
afghanistan the un says the money is
needed to avert a humanitarian crisis in
the country following the taliban
takeover millions of people are said to
be on the verge of starvation the
pledges were paired with demands that
the taliban take steps to respect human
rights
the un says money would go to maintain
medical services water supply and
sanitation other projects in support of
women and children's education will also
receive funding
u.n chief antonio guterres says the
money will be a critical lifeline for
many afghans
the people of afghanistan need a
lifeline
after decades of war suffering and
insecurity
they face perhaps their most perilous
hour
now is the time for the international
community to stand with them
today
one in three afghans do not know where
their next meal will come from
the poverty rate is spiraling and basic
public services are close to collapse
even before the taliban returned to
power the country relied heavily on
international support but now life has
become much worse and many people lack
food and sufficient medical care
we can speak now to linda tom she's with
the united nations in kabul linda thank
you for joining us so tell us what the
biggest challenges are at the moment
um today in afghanistan we are on the
brink of a humanitarian catastrophe this
is due to 40 years of conflict for
current natural disasters and now we're
experiencing the second drought in four
years
that combined with a looming economic
crisis has been a deadly combination for
people in afghanistan
even before
the last couple of months of turmoil
already at the beginning of the year
half the population that's 18 million
people were in need of humanitarian
assistance in afghanistan
it is a dire situation we know that the
united nations has just secured a
billion dollars in aid pledges but
that's for a population of well over 30
million people who are facing as you
just said an economic crisis drought
many other factors
can that money make a difference
of course that money can make a
difference and i wanted to say that in
the past couple of weeks aid workers
are doing the best they can they are
working very hard in order to deliver
assistance to people in need so just in
the past couple of days we've seen um
tens of metric tons of food medicine
arriving in afghanistan
to be deployed immediately to hospitals
and to people who need assistance and
aid workers are working in order to make
sure that assistance gets to people in
need
and what are you hearing from un aid
workers on the ground at the moment what
is the greatest need that they are
assisting with is it food supplies is it
medical supplies
well all these areas are extremely
critical but as the world food program
has said that they're at risk of running
out of food in the next couple of weeks
and
the world health organization has also
said that while they are receiving
supplies of medicine much much more is
needed because of the
large amount of people who need
humanitarian assistance um many people
have been displaced this year so just
this year 600 000 people have been
displaced so they need shelter um like
all of us they just need a safe place to
live and they need their children to be
able to go to school um and um in some
cases it's just even basic things like
water and sanitation among these immense
needs linda are you worried about or aid
arriving where it should arrive under
this current taliban regime
well as i just highlighted you know
we're um we're it's it's a very good
sign that we're able to continue to get
assistance coming in by air but also by
road so um that flow of humanitarian
assistance needs to continue but one of
the issues that we were facing is that
we were running out of funding um so it
was really important that we get renewed
fundings and and um that the pledges um
are uh come in as quickly as possible so
that we can turn those pledges and that
money into medicine into food
and into actual supplies that can help
people on the ground right now
linda tom with the un office for the
coordination of humanitarian affairs
joining us there from kabul thank you
very much
thank you so much for having me
let's take a look at some of the latest
developments in afghanistan right now
the taliban have denied that one of
their top leaders mula abdulgani baradar
was killed in a shootout with rivals
that statement follows rumors about
splits within the movement a u.s
secretary of state anthony blinken has
defended the biden administration's
withdrawal from afghanistan lincoln
insisted to the u.s congress that
officials had prepared for the worst
case scenario and an international
journalists group says the return of the
taliban is a catastrophe for journalism
in afghanistan which is in danger of
disappearing from the country
the german military evacuated more than
5 000 people from kabul after the city
fell to the taliban but more than 10 000
people were still on the foreign
ministry's evacuation list when the
airlift ended on august 27th most of
them afghan citizens they include
journalists human rights activists and
others who could face taliban reprisals
if they remain in the country many are
still waiting for germany to offer them
secure ways out
it is a nerve-wracking wait also for
their afghan relatives already in
germany in berlin we met nargis a
student who was trying to get german
politicians not to look the other way
nagis carries money fundraised for
afghanistan by her school in berlin
the 20 year old afghan came to germany
with her parents and siblings five years
ago they fled the taliban
but some of her relatives are still
stuck in afghanistan
she worries most for her aunt a
politician who is now in hiding in kabul
suicide
she doesn't leave the house anymore
she was politically active and stood up
for a lot so she knows if she goes out
it's dangerous it's a matter of
is not even sure if her aunt is
officially registered by the german
government as a person in need of
protection
and
i feel very powerless here in germany
helpless just completely lost in
afghanistan
gibbs anna's the coaster
mentally successful there is a very big
humanitarian crisis in afghanistan and
germany is just looking the other way
the whole world is
thinks she is the only hope left for her
relatives in afghanistan and she's using
every opportunity to raise her voice
she spoke with olaf schultz german
finance minister and chancellor
candidate for the social democrats but
the conversation left her disappointed
he talks a lot while he's campaigning
but in reality he isn't doing anything
i just wonder how olaf shots can talk
about security family and being together
even though we're living in a completely
different world here
how evacuations from afghanistan might
resume is largely up to the german
foreign ministry
nargis has submitted her family's
information but hasn't received an
answer yet
she says the wait is unbearable
it is a bit hard as a young woman a
student a girl just struggling with
everything with the whole world
because i am just a girl and like all my
other friends my biggest worry should be
what am i going to wear tomorrow i want
that to be my biggest worry and not
having to fight with the world
come from
we can speak now with teresa she's been
working with the initiative kabul
airlift in these past weeks trying to
evacuate afghans and she's joining us
from islamabad in pakistan teresa good
to have you with us so tell us how you
do get people out of afghanistan at the
moment our initiative started in the
beginning with the chartering flights
and um
we managed to evacuate people from from
the hamid kaza international airport
when it was still functioning when the
foreign troops were still there at the
moment we're trying to get people across
the land borders to uzbekistan
tajikistan and pakistan
and once people get to those bordering
countries what happens then
well so far it's been quite difficult to
get them to these countries once they
get there they should be processed by
the german foreign ministry the german
embassies on the ground
and um receive a visa to go to germany
however it's been very very difficult
for these people to get to the country
we've managed to bring
some people across
but what these people really need at the
moment are a verbal note it's a
diplomatic document that tells the
neighboring countries of afghanistan
that germany will take these people to
germany
so should the german government then
essentially be doing more to get afghans
out of the country and also provide them
passage to germany
absolutely absolutely i mean they were
they're about 50 000 people that are on
the official evacuation list that
includes people in danger and their
family members the german government has
so far
uh evacuated about 10 of that number and
a lot of people find themselves in limbo
because i mean today we we got the news
that
germany would accept more than 2 000
people from the humanitarian list but so
far these are mere words they have no
actions been following up with these
words meaning that if um we from kabul
if we send our people to the pakistani
border right now they'd have no way of
entering because despite having issued
words the german embassy in islamabad
for example has not been issuing these
diplomatic notes these verbal notes for
people to actually cross the border and
be transported to germany to safety
and give us an idea i mean is it still
possible to evacuate people who want to
leave or is this a window of opportunity
closing
no it's absolutely still possible it's
it's
the german government would simply need
to issue
these diplomatic nodes these verbal
nodes and then people could cross into
neighboring countries gets a permit to
stay there for a certain amount of time
before moving onward to germany this is
just not happening quickly enough
despite the assurances that it will
happen for certain people
also there are talks about the airport
reopening the pakistani
airline it has been flying into kabul
airport so there are definitely options
to evacuate the people
today who's been working with the
initiative kabul airlift thank you so
much for joining us here on dw